welcome
we're just driving lane was here on 083
the new audi
just testing it out we're driving on the
very sunny roads where usually the old
mall used to struggle with detecting the
lane lines
as you can see they're very washed out
in the image i don't know if you really
see that
but yeah the old model used to struggle
quite a lot with this so this is a good
test
see how it's going i thought we just
take it for a drive
hi everyone sure everyone 083 is like on
our local commute
here full intent let's go
someone said one to end yeah end to end
is super exciting we're finally
fulfilling the dream of comma which is
watch people drive and try to
mimic that behavior yeah 0x3 is really a
big step forward for um for open pilot
hopefully it's the first of many
improvements to come
yeah i guess explain for people who
don't understand what
end to end means in the simplest
possible terms
what it is um what n10 lateral really
really yeah end to end is different from
what we were shipping before in that
before we were
using uh just a mall that detect where
the lane lines are
and then we use the location of the lane
lines to plan a trajectory
you know in the middle of the lane
basically
but that's different from just training
a model that
tries to understand where humans would
drive so not thinking about lane lines
really specifically but just
looking at a road and planning a route
that looks similar to where a human
would drive
and then just driving that trajectory so
this end-to-end model is trained that
way so we just give it a lot of data of
how humans drive
and then we try to tell it to drive like
that and
it's been a very there's many many
challenges involved with getting that to
work
uh which we kind of tried to explain in
the blog post and this is really the
first release where we've got something
that
at least kind of works and it works
pretty well
you can drive on it for hours and not
really notice too many issues
yeah it does work really well especially
like you said on roads like this where
the whole
model would struggle with detecting
the lanes because the lines because
they're so washed out and it just yeah
you don't know exactly where to drive
yeah it doesn't suffer from these like
kind of classification bugs
so we use a segment that just detects in
the image where the lane lines are
and if there's any problems with that
and we have problems like that
with tar lines or with washed out lane
lines then those will
end up causing problems in the final
model but because
this doesn't use segments or anything to
be trained it's just training on how
humans drive
it doesn't suffer from things like that
if you can see in the image
things that humans would use on
determining where to drive
then it should do fine and it's not
really that susceptible to these kind of
bugs
which makes it a much more robust in the
long term
yeah it's super cool like i know there's
one spot on my commute where there's
like a mispainted lane line that briefly
comes like from the left lane line and
uh right
the lane the lane line model would you
know move over to the right
because it the lane line edge kind of is
closer to the right but then laneless
knows that like oh
humans wouldn't follow that little
anomaly in the road
yeah exactly it kind of helps with all
those things and also with other kind of
lane-based things like in europe you
have a lot of uh
like bike lanes on the road basically
which you're allowed to drive on uh but
then the lane line mall detects as a
lane line and tries to drive away from
it but then
the rest of the road is too narrow all
these kind of nuanced things the
landless model
deals much better with which is really
cool
it's just a it's a much more better
long-term strategy and what's super
exciting is that now we finally released
an end-to-end model
we can just keep iterating on that and
keep getting better so that should
hopefully the progress will keep keep
going from here forward because we've
kind of got this kind of full
uh development locked in because we
think it should scale really really well
yeah if someone wants to post this in
the discord go ahead that's usually what
i do but i'm on the street
so feel free to do that
[Music]
i don't think anyone has any questions
or if you think chris there's anything
else that's worth
trying to explain there yeah um
i know some people are asking about and
then longitude though
yeah so that's the exciting thing now i
mean we've been spending years on
getting end-to-end lateral shift it's
been a massive project and we never
really know
how much more we had to do before we got
to a point where it's kind of usable
but now that we're at this stage this
kind of frees up to do more
things because because this is a project
that was occupying most of our time
and ant-man long toothless on that list
anti-longitudinal has some
problems that aren't really true in
lateral which is like
it's very sensitive to mistakes if you
brake very hard or accelerate very hard
at the wrong time
it's kind of pretty uncomfortable
whereas in lateral you can still
override and correct so it is it's i
think
comfort is more important to get it
right from the first time we ship it
um but i think once we get to spend time
on it which should be very soon
i think we'll be able to make progress
quickly hopefully we'll be able to get
slow down for turns that kind of stuff
pretty quickly yeah it's going to be
great
some some people ask what audi is that
oh this is a
audi 2017 a3 yeah prestige does it say
prestige anywhere
i don't know if it does but it's pretty
nice it makes like turbo choo choo
sounds if you uh
if you accelerate it's kind of like a
little
go-kart climb yes it is
and another thing uh in zero eight three
is
like the massive volkswagen mqb platform
push
thanks to jason and the community we
have like
there's over like 10 mpb vehicles added
so it's like a bunch of vws
a golf golf from like 2014 to 2017 and
it probably would work all the way up to
now
mqb is all very similar so all the cars
are
basically identical just with some
slight different tuning
does it work on like the suvs and stuff
too yeah not nice
the the saw or whatever it's called it
works on
um like literally every vw it'll work on
um
so it's really easy to port if someone
has a vw that isn't supported just join
the discord join the volkswagen channel
and
probably someone can help you get it up
and running but
it's very exciting now that volkswagen
has fingerprinting 2.0
that we can just easily detect what car
you're driving
yeah we got some european cars supported
i know that's very exciting hopefully
you can get some more european data
some high-speed german autobahn data and
some of
some some types of data that we're
missing still a little bit
over 90 of our data is still from the us
yeah this is how the model would perform
yeah so this guy's loud isn't he this
truck
yeah so we're still using the audi uh
longitude though apparently it's not
very good i've heard
i don't know i mean it's not as good as
stopped cars
it's not as good as open pilot or some
of the other ones
yeah yeah lateral is much better at lane
changes
those those are kind of not smooth
sometimes the old releases
so that's much improved which is nice
it's true and things like
exit wheat like you know going for exits
and stuff i've never had
yeah much delay
so for anyone who wants to know how to
how to get lane list working
you just have to um
go into toggles of 083 and scroll down
right here it says disable use of lane
lights alpha and of course
it's an experiment so
always be vigilant but it's nice that we
have a toggle people can actually try it
out
really easily so you'll notice your path
is ready to use language that's just to
make it very clear that you've
you're not running in the standard mode
um
one of the things that's still different
with laners which is what we're trying
to work on is
there's not as much corrective pressure
so if you deviate from the path a little
bit let's say i push it over here
it's not going to push back as quickly
as with the lane lines
that's just kind of like a tuning thing
we have to
make the controller you know be aware of
how certain the model is
of driving in a certain place and then
we can make it
aggressive if the model is very sure it
wants to be somewhere else or
smooth if it's not that short it wants
to be somewhere else that's just kind of
a project we haven't really done yet
but yeah once we do that we use the
model's uncertainty
to tune the aggressiveness of the
steering controller we should be able to
uh
prevent like slipping into turns too
much if the road's very banged and it
kind of pushes it into the turn
or having it hug sometimes on some parts
of the wall
yeah yeah someone asked yeah the toggle
will only activate if you
turn your vehicle on and off if you're
like trying to activate a mid-drive that
won't work oh yeah that doesn't work i
mean now it's too for all the talk is
right
exactly yeah any other questions about
zero eight three or the laneless model
let's see
people keep asking if you can use comma
in left-hand drive countries
yeah there's a toggle for that i guess
it's right-hand drive where i guess
right there enable right hand drive
yeah so when you put the toggle two
things happen one is that the driver
monitoring system will start monitoring
the person in the other seat
which is obviously important and the
other is the we actually
input into the driving model that the uh
traffic is now on the left side of the
road and so
uh that should make sure that it doesn't
like always try to go right
on like a two-way road with no other
people
yeah that's super cool
um someone asked will nameless replace
the current model
or does it just adapt for situations
without lanes i guess
um yeah it's kind of a gradual thing
there's situations where the lane lines
won't really work that well
and so in those situations we want to
rely on the blameless model
and as we you know progress with the
quality of lane list that will be more
and more situations
because laneless can do things like if
you pass by a truck close by
a human would kind of go out of the way
a little bit and give the truck more
space
and planets should do that but it's good
enough
so when we're at that stage we kind of
want to use more and more like this
but yeah it's going to be a gradual
thing
yeah that was a good good question but
already right now like
you know we use lane lists if obviously
there's no lane lines when you're going
through an intersection things like that
and when making main changes so
yeah even if you don't have the toggle
enabled
lane changes will be a lot smoother this
release just it's using
a much better laneless model yeah also
when going by
exits and switches to the language
policy because then the lanes
the lane lines go apart so it doesn't
really know what else to do
intersections when landlines are
uncertain it also uses the laneless
policy um
the linux pulse is actually used quite a
lot already
the toggle's just there to make you you
know so you can try out what it's like
if you just drive purely without lane
mics to see what the mall is really
understanding about how
[Music]
i humans drive a pretty pretty cool
pretty cool little feature
yeah and again the way to know if you're
on lane list is you'll see the red
path and there won't be any lane lines
on the screen makes it very clear
if you're on blameless if you're on lane
lance this is white and you have the
white lions of course
um yeah so if you want the improved lane
changes and stuff that's that's all
going to be there
without the toggle since i mean it's the
same model still driving it's just
whether we use the lane lines the model
predicts
uh to plan the path yeah
someone asked if speeds over 90 will be
supported ever
so the speeds over 90 the reason we
reduce the speed is because
we saw from some data that uh at very
high speed
the model can get kind of confused
because we've trained on so little data
of high speed
that uh the model doesn't really know
what's going on it's kind of out of the
training distribution
so it's i mean this is the only reason
we did that as soon as we have enough
data of high speed and that we've
confirmed that the model doesn't get
confused at those speeds
we can raise it again it's just now
we've tested it we know that at this
point
it's getting confused and so as soon as
we have enough high speed data and the
model doesn't get confused anymore
we can increase it again yep
so if you do drive fast just make sure
you upload your data and then that
process will go faster
yeah any of those autobahn users out
there yeah any german autobahn users
i guess that's the most of the high
speed data we see
yeah someone asked um how do we stay so
innovative
we stay so innovative i don't know it's
it's just fun i guess it's fun to
see you guys feedback and see that you
guys like it so
it's very motivating and inspiring to
keep working on it we've got a really
good team
we will feel the same way and all we're
really into solving these problems
yeah it's nice because everyone at comma
drives on the devices and
drives with the models so you know we
can talk about it
at lunch and dinner and how we feel and
stuff and we all just uh
yeah chat about our experience and you
know like a lot it's good that we're
users of our own system i think it's
kind of important to encourage our
development exactly i think it looks
like we're getting the traffic just
maybe i should check it off
yeah it sounds good just engage here
[Music]
yeah someone asked if um big model is
implemented
yeah so big model we kind of have the
training stuff ready to go but there's
some reasons that
we're not really pushing hard on that
yet we've just noticed that most of the
issues
that open pilot has the situations that
struggled with wouldn't really be solved
by big models so it's not
that way it's why it wasn't really a
priority yet
blameless was a much bigger priority
because we think that's the highest
leverage approach to
improve the quality of driving i mean
the
architecture's there uh as soon as we
start seeing that it's a
it's going to help a lot with certain
situations we'll start pushing on
shipping that
yeah yeah brevin asked if uh lane list
will
like move over for semis and stuff yeah
things like that well i don't know does
it
uh it should and it definitely will at
some point i don't know how well it
already works
with the lane line policy you know it's
it's never going to do that just because
it's not designed to ever
react to things like that the lamest
policy is designed to react like that
because humans do
uh i don't know if it's good enough to
do that yet i guess we'll we'll just
have to see
as it will improve at some point it will
start doing those kind of human things
it definitely should move over for like
opposing traffic i've definitely noticed
that if there's
opposing traffic that comes it will kind
of go out of the way a little bit which
makes sense because you know
everyone pretty much does that yeah
so we got the kale model as a tail
and if you want to learn more about the
kale model there's a whole blog post
describing the challenges and how we got
around those
to solving or maybe what it is today
actually i guess
yeah i think tried our best to describe
in this
shortest possible kind of the whole
strategy we use to get to lane smalls
if you're interested in this kind of
stuff you can always come discuss and
discord there's some
some channel about uh with models is the
topic that
people come discuss model stuff that
have interested in so feel free to come
discuss there if you're interested or
have questions about the blog post
yeah cool any
any other questions this is a pretty
comprehensive review or overview of lame
lists i feel like
yeah i'm not sure if there's anything
else we didn't discuss about languages
yeah
someone asked what the next big
challenge is i think we already said
kind of
the longitudinal thing will be another
big challenge right
yeah i think there's two now now that
the lameness works we can really
kind of iterate on that and prove that
so that's going to be a big thing we'll
be working on
and then the other big thing is yeah
trying to start like doing more
end-to-end longitudinal stuff
it'd be nice to do vision based
longitudinal as well without using the
radar so that
all cars will work exactly the same you
don't have to
rely on the radar to get good
performance
yeah that's great
yeah so you know eventually when uh
vision only is good enough
maybe we'll have like a toggle similar
to now and
you know figure all that out later but
that's a far down the road thing
yeah i think yeah we'll look into
whether we can make it work with just a
mob i mean we haven't really spent much
effort on longitudinal in a long time
laterals take a kind of priority so i
think as soon as we
kind of really start working on it again
i'm pretty confident that
we can quickly improve things yeah
slow down for returns will be really
nice to get working
oh yeah that'd be huge i think most of
my disengagements are
you know coming off an exit or whatever
things like that
i mean we've experimented with some
kinds of slow down for charge in the
past but it's always like
it doesn't work super well and if it if
it messes up it's just really
uncomfortable
if it slows down too much you get really
frustrated i promise you can't really
help
with the gas or brake we don't know how
you can override the steering but not
the gas or brake
so mistakes are very you know kind of
intolerable they always lead to a
disengagement
yeah someone said my 2013 golf works
really wow nice that's pretty cool
that's the cool thing with mqb is like
it's been the same for who knows how
long all the messages and everything so
i mean if you have like an old car that
didn't even have lane keep assist it's
probably pretty easy to activate it as
long as you already have you know
adaptive crews on your car
it's pretty fascinating how some cars
keep changing their apis and systems and
volkswagen's just been keeping it the
same this whole time
all yeah so here we're back yeah this is
really the type of road that
um the driving also has kind of
struggled with
uh plane they like to just be really
hard to see because of the sun because
they're so washed out compared to the
light gray road
again for our commute lane this is
definitely uh
helping although the lane lines are also
much better now
in the new new release because we're
using the new segnet
that pencil people have helped create
thank you for all the efforts of
labeling in the common pencil project
huge help yeah all the color pepsi
people are the best yeah
it's really helping us along so that's
true everyone's going to have
better lane line identification no
matter what
next to come a pencil pencil
all right is there anything else i feel
like that was a good overview 0a3
was released a few days ago so if you
have a comma 2
you can get it right now just should
already have prompted you to update
and it's a great time to get a comment
too if you haven't done one already
uh because we have the first release
with working laneless
and you know it's gonna get everybody's
gonna get better as time goes on think
of where we were a year ago
yeah exactly it just keeps getting
better and better every time i think
back to what the old the
things the problems with old releases
i'm just so excited about how far we've
come
yeah it's really crazy so yeah comma 2
is 10.99 and then you can get a harness
for an extra 200 and get a
[Music]
get all the hardware you would need so
all right well we're gonna be driving
back to the office now on lane list
but i guess we'll see you all later
all right that was fun to see you guys
yeah definitely check out the kale post
and if you don't if you have a supported
car definitely
consider checking out a pilot all right
bye everyone bye guys